t14 damn right welcome to wildstar this
is devspeak this disclaimer absolves me
of all responsibility guys I'm gonna be
honest I've been waiting for this
episode my entire life it's all I've
thought about its warplots warplots are
massive strategic glorious 80 player PvP
matches with giant customizable battle
fortresses warplots have seamlessly
combined my love of housing with
high-stakes strategic warfare real talk
I'm a military genius I'm basically
George Washington General Patton and
Charlemagne I take that back and more my
next match will be my greatest triumph
I've crafted I've eluded the finest
defenses I've taken 27 days of PTO for
my war party I've gathered literally the
39 finest warriors from my server we
imagine uniforms and I've developed the
perfect strategy oh crap
they have robots okay Delta Squad will
move in force capturing resource nodes
tango and Charlie securing precious nano
pack to power our rocket launchers
meanwhile cavalry division six will whip
around the flanks to draw the enemy out
making way for the Centurions led by
corporal Jennings worth sent to disable
their precious robot Factory
Jennings were the robots they're not
powering down now all this forces the
enemy to make a foolhardy charge upon
our front gates but I placed a furnace a
laser trap and a nuclear power plant in
the perfect configuration
it's impassable whoa they're passing it
but they have no idea about my secret
weapon I've journeyed deep into the
bowels of Nexus to recover an
unstoppable monster little do they know
Sir Galahad has placed his deployable
landmines perfectly one inch to the left
or more party rating is unmatched you're
all useless Lieutenant Commander data
your uniform why is your belt buckle
yellow yeah okay we're going to need a
random mercenary to finish this oh you
are kidding me to take on my unstoppable
legions pre-order wildstar now and as
always reach out to us the devs are
listening
don't forget to subscribe for more
videos instant builds where did you look
me in the eye
chief medical officer crusher your
weapon is not properly polished Viceroy
Wellington yeah I don't like your face
Admiral Ackbar stop being right all the
time